we like surprises don't we yes we like
surprises well guess what in a surprise
announcement
NASA revealed a new name for its moon
program Artemis she is a Greek goddess
of the moon and twin sister of Apollo
well NASA picked the name in hopes of
having the first woman land on the moon
by 2024 and now in order to meet that
deadline the Trump administration wants
Congress to approve an additional 1.6
billion dollars for NASA on top of its
21 billion dollar budget for next year
MOX
mark Strassmann spoke with a man who's
responsible for making the moonshot
happen mark good morning good morning
NASA's mission popped by fits and starts
for decades now has a new name and a new
urgency the Artemis program intends to
land astronauts on the South Pole of the
Moon in five years four years earlier
than originally planned its ambitious it
will be expensive and NASA needs
commercial and congressional support to
pull it off 50 years ago this July two
Americans left the first footprints in
lunar dust no other country has matched
Apollo's moonwalkers but five have sent
probes and robots including Israel and
China just this year it's not by
accident that so many countries around
the world right now are going to the
moon and not all of them are going to
the moon just to collect rocks it's a
strategic imperative that the United
States have a presence there as well
when Jim bridenstine became NASA's
administrator last year a planned moon
landing was a decade away ladies and
gentlemen that's just not good enough
but in March Vice President Mike Pence
lit a fire under NASA and it's
contractors if NASA is not currently
capable of landing American astronauts
on the moon in five years we need to
change the organization not the mission
we've seen over and over again
administration's change and projects get
cancelled with billions of dollars
wasted of the taxpayer we're going to
shorten the timescale we're gonna make
this a reality that starts by
accelerating development of NASA's new
mega rocket called the Space Launch
System or SLS
top with Syd NASA's new crew capsule
called Orion roughly 240,000 miles from
Earth
Orion eventually would dock with a
planned lunar orbiting space station
called
Gateway but the Artemis program lacks
one key component what's the most
significant piece of the budget increase
the landing capability like lunar
landers are difficult to build they take
time they take money and we don't have
that capability not yet but private
industry wants that contract this is
Blue Moon last week
billionaire Jeff Bezos introduced Blue
Moon his space companies designed for a
lunar lander Lockheed Martin also has a
design 5 years to get to the moon how is
that not fairly intense schedule
pressure if somebody says this isn't
safe ultimately they have the authority
to throw a red flag and say stop it is
more important for us that our
astronauts be safe Brighton's down a
former congressman from oklahoma thinks
he has the votes on Capitol Hill to pass
this new budget hike bigger requests are
sure to follow but without this support
the moon looks awfully far away when
brightest dines at 2024 not 2028 that
was a game-changer I mean intense
schedule constraints and also you have
budget constraints now too
even with this new money it's gonna be a
real push well they will want people to
cover it are you raising your hand
saying I'll go see yes absolutely
absolutely I'm a fast learner
no dessert well I'll be down hesitation
Wow they said a woman had not landed on
the moon we all kind of said it's about
time it's about time I involved 12
people have walked up with qualified
these astronauts these astronauts are
some of the most highly trained
professionals in the world they would
lay would look at me and say nor you
could train crazy overachievers my 12
people walk to the moon all Americans
all men yeah like Mark Norris Lerner
yeah let me tell you something the 21st
century is the century of women it is
we're learning that okay
like you said you're a fast learner mark